hey it's evan and i thought i'd continue
in the monthly update series to let you
know what i'm working on and how things
are going because people keep asking me
about the projects i'm into uh my video
editor christina amazing christina is
going away on vacation i think she
leaves in a couple hours so this video
i'm putting up pure raw no effects
nothing no
zoom ins links nothing because
she does all that and i don't want to
bug her the day she has to leave so
you're getting it
pure from me uh so some quick updates on
my youtube videos
the youtube stuff is still you know it's
a huge part of my life now i do uh
again like two videos every day i sit
down on wednesday and record everything
and the comments that come in every day
from you guys are amazing and uh and
keep me going like i wake up and i look
forward to seeing what new comments have
come in from everybody um i had almost
200 000 views like 171 000 views or
something last month in april uh
it's down because in may i had over two
hundred thousand like yeah here we go
we're growing is awesome uh so it was
the first month now we went down a
little bit but it's still my third best
month ever um so i don't know i'm a
little bummed but i'm also excited that
things are growing and youtube is i love
you guys i love making these videos for
you and hopefully it's having an impact
what else happened in april i launched a
movement program this is where you know
more and more i want to work with
entrepreneurs who really want to make a
difference
you know it's not just about the money
and it's not just about following your
passion but
making a real difference in the world
and i want to work with entrepreneurs
who want to build their movement up i've
seen the tremendous success and growth
that's come from me having believe and
i'm helping other entrepreneurs pick
their one word and coaching them along
the process so i launched a new page on
the site um it's
evancomica.commovement it's also in the
footer at the bottom
and i'm coaching two entrepreneurs right
now through the process and it's it's
really fun it's really fun seeing how
they're developing and making their own
content um and so i have a monthly
coaching call with them that is open
everybody to kind of watch online
uh and so we'll see where it goes i'm
i'm excited i don't have the bandwidth
to take on too many people at once um
but the goal is to get them creating
amazing content and building their own
movement as well getting some real
results from social media
my book i'm working away on it i have uh
almost 5 000 words written in my new
book idea
a lot of people hate the book idea in my
circles the people who have to pitch it
and sell it uh are not fans of it yet
so
i don't know we'll see how it goes we'll
see what happens i feel this book has to
be written
so i am
steadfast i'm writing this book uh i'm
excited by the content
the people who've seen it don't uh they
haven't seen it fully but who have
spoken about it too they don't feel it's
a book they think it's too small
um it's content-wise and it's not
applicable enough but i i like what
are you talking about anyway um
i'm excited by the book we'll see how
much progress i make in the next month
on it uh but 5000 words and counting
the zookas are doing well i'm trying to
make videos for each of the zookas i
feel like um
on the if there's a message from me on
each page it make it more personal and
show the importance of it and how it
impacted my life so
um i've made the first one the mindset
zooka has a video on it and i'm looking
at making more over the next month
uh we're also looking into other ways to
distribute it so it's not just on my
site but through partnerships or through
affiliate programs i don't know which
the which is the best one i'm kind of
hesitant to join like a clickbank
because it seems too
low quality and doesn't show the
importance and high quality like there's
a lot of value that you get in each zuka
that's put out and it's really
affordable um
so i don't know i'm thinking about that
if you guys have options ideas leave it
in the comments below i'd love to hear
from you
i started a new twitter chat series in
april and april was busy uh with dell
and it's basically once a month now
we're gonna do it uh second thursday of
every month in the afternoon i think
it's 12 30 to 1 30. anyway at the bottom
of my site in the footer it says chat
and that's where you can find out more
uh the first one was great we set
records tons of great feedback lots of
great people participating i was
answering questions uh for like days
beyond so it was awesome uh i really
love connecting with everybody because
it's you know i'm sitting here right now
i'm at my house um
i don't have everybody in a room right
where i get to meet you i love the
presentations but uh it's great to
connect with you and know that you're
engaging with the staff and you're
liking it
uh on my articles i don't talk too much
about my website but on the articles we
have i have a lot of authors who
contribute their content um to my
website and i'm trying to focus it more
on engagement now i realize that my
favorite part of my day is seeing my
comments come in from youtube and
twitter and all that and
i want other people to experience that
as well and so i'm trying to put a new
focus on comments on the articles to
encourage people when i read an article
to leave a comment on it so whoever
wrote that article
will feel as good as i do every day when
they get comments
on the movement side i'm trying to also
think a way of a way is there
is a way to help other
people who are trying to support
entrepreneurs and there's a video coming
out on this that that uh i already
recorded that hasn't been released yet
so it's coming soon but i got all the
people right into me who
who want to help with my projects like
evan can we translate your videos or
evan can we
do some graphic design for you or they
just want to help which is awesome it's
mind-blowing that people want to you
know volunteer and help
uh and there's other people who have
great projects who who could use help
right like i want to launch this thing
but i don't have a programmer or i don't
have a graphic designer or whatever and
they're trying to do something good to
help entrepreneurs and i'm wondering if
there's a way to combine all this into
into uh one home so that if you want to
help on one of my projects or if you
want to
create your own or help out on somebody
else's is a there's a place to go to
to uh to look at the projects and and
help out you know you know that your
work is helping out other entrepreneurs
um so anyway you have thoughts on that
leave a comment below if you like it or
not or if you have some ideas uh but
there is another video coming out on
that where i talk more in detail so
leave a comment on that one for sure
and then on a personal level um
what can i say on a personal level uh
i'm doing a salsa music video
a band reached out to me and they said
we want you to dance
uh to our song and film it and we'll put
in our music video and they're reaching
out to people from different countries
so i'm gonna go to center island
tomorrow
uh which is in toronto where you can see
a nice view of the cn tower and i'm
gonna be doing some salsa dancing to the
song and film it and hopefully gets used
in a music video
i'm now a level 10 in league of legends
jason introduced me to league of legends
we made a video on it but it's super
long and christina hasn't edited it yet
so uh
slowly working my way up nina is up is
pretty obsessed with the game and so i
get recruited to to play with her so uh
yeah level 10 right now and uh you know
what if you guys have fun ideas or
things that i could do to surprise nina
let me know in the comments hopefully
she doesn't watch this video and read
the comments she gets a heads up but uh
let me know what you think
uh and um
yeah maybe i'll film it while i'm doing
it that'd be a pretty fun video anyway
that's my april update i guess may
now getting into it um
just so you kind of see what i'm up to
and i appreciate all your support
love you guys you guys really make my
day every day you keep me going and uh
keep commenting keep
keep you know following your dream keep
helping out other entrepreneurs and let
me know if you like this series this
monthly update series on what i'm doing
and i'll keep that going too so thank
you guys leave a comment below give it a
thumbs up if you like it and i'll see
you soon